walking on holy ground a group of young
Native American activists visit Quito
but Quito Springs an oasis in the vast
desert of the organ pipe cactus National
Monument
it's a place where according to
archeologists people have gathered for
more than 16,000 years we came from this
land we wouldn't be here if it weren't
for the spring giving us life the organ
pipe cactus national monument spans 1340
square kilometers of pristine desert
named for a species of desert plants
that grow here and no place else on
earth it's the traditional territory of
the tea a chat Odom and Tohono autumn
sacred for the people that lived here in
the ceremonies that we conducted here
are our ancestors did and pretty much
all of our cultural practices but just
50 kilometers away President Donald
Trump's massive border wall is going up
the nine meter tall metal structure will
cut through traditional lands and will
require new roads bulldoze through the
monument and the adjacent to hona autumn
reservation Native Americans say the
wall will damage ceremonial sites
pilgrimage routes and ancient graveyards
here in the organ pipe cactus National
Monument a government survey has
identified at least 22 significant
archaeological sites that would be
partially or completely destroyed by
border wall construction tribal elder
Elfi Leah Rivas is organizing a
grassroots effort to direct public
attention to what she says is an act of
cultural desecration
when these borders to go up this metal
borders or these fences go up it very is
very destructive to our spiritual being
and our way of life and any part of it
that is destroyed it is taking us apart
it's piece by piece activists say they
will do everything in their power to
stop the wall I think there's many of us
that are willing and ready to put our
bodies on the line despite the vast
resources of the federal government
Marshall behind Trump's signature
political project the native people here
say they will not give up we've existed
here since the beginning of time and
they will continue to to exist even
after this wall is built a place of
natural beauty ecological diversity and
cultural significance that may soon be
changed forever
Rob Reynolds al-jazeera kotoba Quito
Springs Arizona